foreign
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people
do work they love build wealth and
create actual amazing relationships
thanks for joining us America the call
is free triple eight eight two five five
two two five as I said it's free and
some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it Ramsay personality
number one best-selling author and host
of the Ken Coleman Show Ken Coleman is
my co-host today he is the Ramsay
personality in charge of getting your
butt to work I mean he helps you get
jobs and work and uh and he will put the
Lash across get to work yeah yeah that's
it and so triple eight eight two five
five two two five we'll help you with
your career aspirations your Jab
your money and your life it's what we do
here triple eight eight two five five
two two five and he starts this hour in
Sacramento hi Annie welcome to the
Ramsey Show oh it's Ann hi Ann welcome
to the Ramsay show hi hi thank you so
much for taking
me sure
I have I I just have a question I I I'm
in a quandary and I would appreciate
your advice so I recently received uh
about 350
000 of inheritance money from my sweet
hard-working industrial parent wow and
um yeah and I I really don't want I
really want to maximize the potential of
it
um and I'm in my mid 50s my husband's in
the late 50s you know it's time to for
sure make sure that we have anyway
um we would like to buy some real estate
but we're looking outside of California
because
um California is very landlord
unfriendly and also the multiples
anywhere around our house you just can't
find the multiples for the maximum
return on investment and for Building
Wealth so what do you think because I
know that you tend to like have found
real estate close by
yeah long distance landlording generally
doesn't end well
and yeah because it's just very hard to
keep your eyes on the property your eyes
on even if you have a property
management firm your eyes on the
property management firm uh you know you
need to drive by your property every so
often I drove by one of ours the other
day and I went good Lord we need to cut
those bushes you know and for some
reason no one else had thought that so
no one watches it quite like you do even
if you've got a good property management
team and I do
um but uh that's the problem is you just
never see it it's out of sight out of
mind and it could be completely torn
down and you would never know it unless
somebody told you and that's that's the
thing that bothers me about it so I
don't disagree with how you got to your
question the multiples are crazy and the
laws are crazy it is California after
all and um so I mean it's just crazy
land so what do I know but yeah
I love you people in California but
anyway the uh uh some of you and the um
anyway that's the thing I don't know
have you got any debt
no not good no our house is paid off and
you know we just we don't like that we
kind of like you that way we just don't
like it yeah so if if I were going to do
it and I wouldn't do it but you have
good reasons for considering it in your
case if I were going to go I would want
something that I could access
and get to frequently for other reasons
like have you got relatives in a town
that is got better multiples in a good
real strong real estate market
I don't know reasons to go visit is what
I was looking for okay no you don't then
okay because like oh my sister and I go
see her three times a year and she lives
in Phoenix okay well let's talk about
Phoenix you know then or something like
that but you don't so that's that but it
you know an airport connection to
Sacramento which is there's a lot of
that's not a problem uh assuming the
other end works and um you know
something where you're gonna Bop over
there and go hey we're going to go over
there twice a year and you know uh stay
in a hotel and enjoy the place and we're
going to San Antonio enjoy the Riverwalk
and we're going to have a property there
you know or something but you gotta have
a reason to go around be around it
because you're putting a very precious
portion of your money otherwise I would
just do some mutual funds
yeah Dave that's that my question Dave
is is the return on that on the rental
property because you've got a lot of
them you understand that versus the
return on investing the way we teach
with this sum of money where does she
come out best yeah if you get a well-run
rental property it's more hassle right
but you're going to make more money on a
well-run rental property than your own
mutual funds but it's a lot more hassle
so and you got extra risk here because
now we've got it in this mythical city
that I just made up so we'll call it San
Antonio and so you know you're going to
be bopping over there and uh or what
would be closer in Boise you could jump
over to Boise right uh that's not a bad
jump from Sacramento uh that kind of a
thing yeah and uh you know you might you
could do that but you need to go you
know uh we're we're going to buy an
injection hole because we go skiing
twice a year you know or whatever I
don't know but uh just think about where
you're doing that otherwise I would keep
it real simple and just go to mutual
funds you're going to make a little less
return but you're going to have a lot
less risk because of your situation
being in out of state and that kind of a
thing I do not buy properties out of
state except for toys that I live in and
play in but not for rental and so I've
got properties but they're they're the
stuff that we go hang out at you know
it's not we don't we don't rent them and
so um and that's a pain in the butt
because I got to get people to work on
them yeah right because the more stuff
you own the more repairman you have to
know it's a rule so you're telling me
when you drove by that house the other
day and saw the bushes you didn't pull
the truck over and pulled out your
little my little chain get my chainsaw
out of my truck you're telling me you
didn't do that I was close I almost went
back to the barn and got a chainsaw but
no I'll let somebody else do it and man
it looks better too it looks like it got
a haircut and it needed one yeah yeah
you know those ugly bagworm bushes that
grow up and take over the whole corner
of the house yeah that's cute when you
put them out they are they're not cute
when they grow up they get Gnarly
beasties that's right so yeah just
destroy the whole curb appeal it was
awful so yeah real estate is a wonderful
place to put money folks especially
right now it's a good time to buy real
estate whether you're doing it as an
investment whether you're buying a home
even with the rates where they are yeah
even with the rates where they are rates
go back down just refinance if you're
borrowing but you're not going to borrow
to invest if you're around here anyway
but the the point is you can make more
money on real estate it's good yeah but
you've got to choose it carefully
and it needs to be something that's a a
predictable outcome don't try to get
these uh unique properties
um unique property means very limited
market yeah right that's what that means
and when you get that means it's going
to have very limited uh resale value
because you've limited customers when
you're getting ready to resell it so
it's increase in value is very limited
so do those tend to be white elephants
yeah of course yeah some very unique
it's a cool property but you know you
buy a uh
you know a a highly contemporary piece
of architecture in a town that's a civil
war town and it's full of antebellums
you know right you just you just bought
a white elephant Bubba I mean or vice
versa you put up an antebellum in the
middle of a dead gum you know modern
town full of contemporary same situation
you just built yourself a white elephant
and uh it's a problem you're gonna get
yourself in a mess that that's but it's
a good question thank you for calling in
we'll help you anytime you jump in here
that's what we're for this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place here's
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today safe
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book
paycheck to purpose is my co-host today
today's question of the day sponsored by
neighborly your hub for Home Services as
the weather warms up neighborly can help
you find local service pros like the
Grounds Guys five-star painting and
mosquito Joe which you would need in
Nashville ah to turn your yeah we've
caught mosquitoes the size of eagles
here and to turn your outdoor space into
your favorite space and help you find
all the help you need at neighborly.com
we're so honored to have them as a
sponsor now and April is National
financial literacy month all month long
teachers and students in classrooms
Across America are taking the time to
talk about the importance of learning
money skills today's question comes from
Alex in Minnesota how do you create a
budget that works when you are young and
your income is inconsistent and
unpredictable predictable so on this one
Dave we've got a young person presumably
a student who doesn't have a lot of
household expenses he's living at home
potentially and what we want to focus on
there is what are your expenses what are
Mom and Dad requiring of you are you
doing gas money helping out with some of
your insurance whatever that is what are
your spending habits things you're
saving for and I think the budget there
Dave is kind of created around that when
you don't have a livelihood or the four
walls that we teach exactly exactly and
that's what we teach kids students in
the High School curriculum foundations
and personal finance is taught in 48
percent of the high schools in America
now our high school curriculum is and
what we teach folks there Alex is
exactly what Ken said your purpose of
doing a budget when you're in high
school or junior high school either one
is not to become wealthy
it's not to become a master budget
person it's to start to build the muscle
of telling your money what to do instead
of wondering where it went
which by the way is all a budget is
adults devise a plan and follow it
children regardless of their age do what
feels good
and so if you're 52 and you do what
feels good you are by definition
emotionally a child
you're immature
I I deserve it oh shut
up shut up you don't deserve anything
you haven't earned that's when you
deserve it
you're not entitled to a new car I work
so hard oh really you're the only one
you whiner okay so that's a child
regardless of if they're 12 or they're
52 and we hear them all the time saying
stuff like that well you don't know yes
I do know I've done it all I'm old okay
and so I've seen it all heard it all
it's the thing is so the whole thing
here Alex is to get you the other side
of that and say okay as an adult because
we're training young people to be good
adults and training young people to be
good adults involves telling your money
what to do instead of wondering where it
went and so all you got to do is go this
month or I want to buy a car by
September
okay how are we gonna do that
yeah and so you begin to go okay if it's
a five thousand dollar car my mom and
dad are going to match whatever I come
up with so let's say they're going to
match your 2500 and you begin to say all
right how much money do I need to make
got five months I need 500 bucks I gotta
get after it and this is interesting
Dave what I love about financial
literacy and something that you just
said I want to add to
the reason we have movements right now
among a lot of young people on social
media that's called the anti-work
movement is because they've never been
taught real financial literacy because
this young man you take this question
right here and he begins to understand
what we just said to him he begins to
tell us money what to do the budget as
Dave just laid out here's what happens
individual responsibility flourishes
when you get taught that you can have
enough money but this anti-work movement
all this junk that's out there is coming
from young people who've never been
taught how to manage their money and
thus they don't have enough and then
they begin to say I work too hard I
don't have enough money I want the
government to supply me the money and
and I'm not trying to make this
political because it's not it's actually
sociological when you understand how to
handle money as a young person with what
we teach in financial literacy month
everything we're doing control your
destiny they if you'll get off your
little butt and then they become hard
workers because they go I like what
money allow allows me to do I can be
generous I can be helpful I can be calm
I don't have to be pissed off all the
time that's true right you know it's
just this is all goes together see I
thought the anti-work movement was
because College professors were students
of Karl Marx and had passed that along
to college students and reinforced the
fact that they got a participation
trophy instead of keeping score when
they were playing soccer and they were
sick well you just nailed the two other
reasons right but the reasons those
message stick is because when you don't
have any money and you're broke those
messages make more sense yeah but to
somebody who's got money you go what are
you talking about that's a pay cut if
you're 55 years old you know it's more
fun to score there's that
you just do right I mean you don't have
to be a you don't have to be a
psychologist to figure this one out you
smile more when you score than when you
don't score so go score that's what work
is it's score go to score it's what it
is just go score yeah go put the ball in
the hoop man that's what you do right
and and you're going to have more joy
and more dignity and more choices when
you do that now Alex has not got that
problem he's a guy asking a question on
this right he's ready he's a great young
man and so I mean we got a lot of great
young people out there that's right but
we do have a group of participation
trophy graduates our intent on making
mediocrity their goal and uh it's a
problem it is and by the way this is
what leads to credit card debt at an
all-time high student loans all-time
high I've got to rely on somebody else
to give me money so that I can get the
life I want and that is counterintuitive
and it leads to record numbers of 28
year olds living in their mother's
basement
seven million men not working because
they don't like their job staff and as
the lady on CBS news said the other day
that's highly unattractive
that's right hard to get a date yeah
it's true it's true you don't feel real
eligible because you're not right he's a
dreamer Daddy yeah that's right he is
that's all he does that's right yeah it
means you're gonna live in my basement
you're dating a dreamer oh God help me
yeah I'd love for you to say he's a doer
please tell me he's a doer yes he has
Big Dreams and he's doing things to make
those dreams come true that I like I
like that a lot yeah see this is highly
attractive you know it turns out
mediocrity is really kind of smelly well
it's miserable they can try to put
another label on it but a person who's
leading or cool beating the man by being
a communist yeah well you'll notice that
anybody who says these kind of things on
social media is always angry I tell you
what you never see an angry capitalist
an angry person with a lot of money and
options you see anger where I feel
limited and they start by being limited
financially because we don't teach
Financial financial literacy Ramsey
Solutions does that's why we're in
schools but if we don't teach this then
what happens is they come through the
system Dave and the system tells them uh
you need a credit card so that you have
a backup plan you need to get a student
you need a credit score two hundred
thousand dollars in debt to get a degree
in left-handed puppets so you can be
successful and you can be a barista
right oh by the way the only people
winning in that system are the people
given the loans and the credit cards
interestingly enough they're the ones
that are winning big credit cards at an
all-time I'm going to stick it to the
man I'm gonna make sure he gets really
rich
right and if they're upset against rich
people the people ought to be a set
against are the are the financial
purveyors of all of the mediocrity and
frustration in your life see that's the
game you want to be mad at somebody it's
the people who make really awesome
commercials selling your credit card
they're the best commercials on TV
here's the thing if your job sucks
I mean you're not in Russia no just go
get another one that's right if your
boss sucks right get you another one
that's exactly right well here's this
hard yeah well the gig economy is
exploding right now Dave freelance work
people can get out of debt faster we've
had nurses call in on this program I
don't like what Walmart pays that's
right don't worry they go work somewhere
else uh We've we got an unbelievable job
economy right now 3.6 Unemployment uh my
goals was never to work at McDonald's
it was never a goal of mine yeah that's
yeah unless it's the one by the way
that's the one I own in St Thomas but
right you know no thank you all right
and that's no one's goal but see we live
in a world now where you don't have to
go work at McDonald's you can go start
your own business online today I I never
had to that's the point I know I used to
cut grass and I my buddies this was a
thousand years ago when dinosaurs roamed
the Earth my buddies were making a
dollar 65 minimum wage
wow this is how long ago it was true
story I was 12 years old
and I cut grass for three dollars for a
yard and I figured out I could cut the
grass in one hour so I was making double
what my buddies were making as Whopper
floppers so I've never been held to the
standard of I am forced to do something
yes and you aren't either you can choose
to go do anything you want to do boys
and girls this is still America that's
right it's weirder America than ever
before but it's still America this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us
this is common sense for your life
common sense for your dollars and cents
it's called the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five if you
are a new listener and based on the
ratings and the rankings that we get
frequently we have a whole bunch of new
listeners thank you very very much
we're in the top 15 podcasts in the
entire world of any kind wow I need to
call my mom real quick dude you should
you should call her right now you should
have called her earlier but now you can
call her but and um you know you've got
something to tell her yes finally and uh
yeah so I mean really that's out of
millions of podcasts literally without
it without exaggeration we're in the top
15. and we know all of these things so
we know there's a bunch of you new out
there thank you and uh if you're new and
you don't know what we're talking about
around here or say code words like
Ramsey code words like baby steps or
debt snowballs or stuff like that then
uh it's pretty simple just go to the
ramseysolutions.com website it's free
click on get started it's free and we'll
help you figure out where you are and
what your next steps are and it's free
did I mention it's free so
ramseysolutions.com click get started
and we'll walk you through this process
Pam's in Flagstaff Arizona hi Pam how
are you
I'm doing good thank you
um I'll try to make this quick uh I'm 69
my husband is 70 and he's still working
but I want him to retire and I have been
putting money away and money away and my
bank told me that
part of our money is not covered by FDIC
I think I got that right correct and I
don't know what to do with
over that okay
well we've got 250 000 and coverage each
so 500 000 if it's got both of your
names on it
um in a typical bank so you're sitting
on over a half million dollars cash
okay but they told me
the way you've got to set up okay you
can just move the other uh if you want
to keep it all in cash just move it to a
different bank
under what
is I mean what's it under now
savings okay I mean hopefully okay
there's two issues here the question you
asked in the question you didn't ask
okay the question you asked was how do I
get FDIC Insurance each Bank can give
you 250 000. so as long as you don't
have more than 250 in any Bank you have
coverage total of all of your accounts
in that bank okay so if you have 10
Accounts at the bank this total cannot
total up more than 250 if you want FDIC
coverage now number two there's three
questions two um you didn't ask number
two I don't think your bank's in
dangerous I think your bank's fine okay
svb bank is was an anomaly it is a we're
it was a weird Bank of a bunch of
players a bunch of venture capitalist
Goobs in techville called Silicon Valley
and they were a bunch of high-tech
high-risk companies dumped a whole bunch
of cash in there and the bank was out of
control your bank in Flagstaff Arizona
is very likely not out of control I have
more than the FDIC limit in my bank and
I am zero nervous about it
okay that's question number two no
question number three is why are you
sitting on 350 000 in cash why don't we
invest some of it
because I didn't think stupidity on my
part I didn't think at our age investing
money would be a good idea or any either
one of you ill
uh that depends on which one you ask
Ed I didn't ask if you're a
hypochondriac I asked if you were really
ill
that's a great answer
you're awesome you're amazing man you're
my favorite call of the day I love it
well I I did have cancer and I had
surgery and I have to go back every
three months to get checked okay but
you're not current you're currently in
remission
yeah okay and uh is your husband ill
seriously not mental physically okay
okay
specify your questions
be clear right now and be clear if you
let her into that one be clear radio man
okay
all right so um here's the thing uh
there's a high likelihood
let's pretend that you're 69 and you
live 10 years
okay if you have 350 000 and it makes
you one percent that is thirty five
hundred dollars
if you have 350 000 and it makes you ten
percent that's thirty five thousand
dollars thirty thousand dollar
difference
for ten years is 300 more thousand
dollars that not investing the money
could be costing you
okay you're losing about 30 grand a year
twenty five hundred dollars right okay
what I would tell you to do is I want
you to sit down I want you to go slow
okay but I want to activate you to not
leave it in all in a bank making no
money okay you basically buried it in a
coffee can in the backyard is basically
what you've done you didn't mean to but
you did and so um I want you to make
more on it so I want you to click on a
smartvester at Ramsey Solutions sit down
with an investment professional let them
begin to teach you do not do this
because I said do it do not do it
because they said do it do it because
after learning over a series of two or
three meetings that you learn about a
type of mutual fund that you can put
this in that you feel safe you have
peace about investing okay okay yeah and
if you have peace about investing then
you can do the numbers that I was
talking about I'm not that much younger
than you I'm 62 going on three and all
of my investments are in mutual funds
and in real estate none of it is sitting
in the bank or the I've got money
sitting in the bank but it's business
money for the operations of this company
not money that I'm counting on for
retirement and so all of my long-term
money that I'm going to be eating with
is invested because I don't want to make
3 000 per
300 I want to make 35 000 per 300 for
per 300 and that's that's what I want
you to learn about but I want you to do
that with peace and your husband to have
peace about it
um now if both of you are going to be
gone in a year it doesn't matter but if
you make it 10 years or 15 years then it
matters a lot yeah and I think the key
here is with Dave tolding you telling
you to sit down with somebody and they
explain it to you you can see the
numbers you can see the historic
percentages and stop paying attention to
the headlines I would sit with a pro and
get your head out of the news and then
once you understand it and you're not
gripped by fear you're going to be in a
much better position I think that's good
advice for all of us as it relates to
investing stop paying attention to the
news and sit down with real pros who
know what they're doing and look at the
history of the stock market look at the
history of the returns based on the
investment strategy that we teach when
you look at it it's mind-blowing about
how effective it is yep absolutely Amy
is with us in Dallas Texas hi Amy
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Mr Ramsey Mr Coleman how are you guys
great how can we help
um I think just you know in a nutshell
I'm kind of
a little scared on how to manage the
balance between giving my kids
every advantage in the world because I
can versus also making sure they learn
the value of you know how hard we work
for the money that we have and you know
I don't know just just that balance you
know well I protected my kids from harm
by protecting them from harm and by
teaching them to work
yeah both and I know like am I giving
them a better Advantage by paying for
their school or you know college like
because that's going to be preparing for
their college doesn't ruin them uh if
you've taught them to work I paid for my
kids college but all of them have really
strong work ethic as adults but we
started when they're four years old by
God you clean your room yeah
and let me add to this also let them
fail teaching them to work is one thing
put them in situations to learn and try
new things whether it be an instrument
or a sport and let them learn how to
fail we have removed the pain of failure
from these kids and therefore they grow
up with no grit so they can't work hard
because they have nothing to give yeah
but we're not sending them to the salt
mine
we're protecting please don't do that we
love them we're gentle with them but
when you're four you clean up your room
when you're 14 by God you clean up your
room you know I mean this is it this is
the Ramsey Show
thank you
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsay personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today let's do a little mental exercise
look ahead 90 days from now it's July
you've got a thousand dollars sitting in
the bank that you didn't have today two
of your credit card payments are gone
and you check out at the grocery store
without having a panic attack
you know how that would feel we call it
Financial Peace it's the first steps
towards real wealth building and getting
free
from the debt monster
some of you have never had that in your
entire life
but today's the day you can take control
of your money starts with Financial
Peace University FPU is our nine-week
course that's helped millions of people
beat debt build wealth and become
outrageously generous
we're going to teach you everything
about how to handle your money step by
step so you don't have to worry about it
anymore the average FPU graduate has an
eight thousand dollar turnaround in just
90 days they save 2 300 bucks and pay
off 5790 days
eight thousand bucks richer in three
months on your way to being baby steps
millionaires that means before summer
break is over you're going to feel
completely different
about your money Financial Peace
University started today at
ramsaysolutions.com FPU
ramsesolutions.com FPU Kyler's in Salt
Lake City hi Kyler how are you
good how are
you better than I deserve what's up
so I uh I recently found out my uh my
grandpa passed away about eight months
ago nine months ago
um and uh found out through my dad that
he had wanted to give
um the remaining amount of his money his
house his cars
um the total sum of that money to his
grandkids
um and so
looking at what that would be
um it's looking like it's going to be
about 125 thousand dollars per grandkid
so
um to give you a little back uh sense of
kind of where we're at I'm married I'm
22 my wife's 20.
um we uh we just bought a house we moved
in about two days ago we got married
about eight months ago stayed with my
dad in his basement for those eight
months
um saved that money was able to uh put
it down on down payment got a house with
the ability to rent um and so that's
covering about 70 75 of our mortgage
right now because we do have a renter in
there
um so we have no debt I have no school
debt no car debt
um my wife doesn't have any school debt
as well and so we're kind of in this you
know what should we do with that much
money you know how does that how can we
use that to set us up
um to just kind of want to see what you
guys how to think about that I had to
say about that
it's a very good question and you're
very wise to ask that question a lot of
people don't they just get the money and
then two years later they wonder what
happened to it it just leaves and we
have no idea where it went
um happens to a lot of people uh so good
for you you're way ahead of the Curve
I'm sorry about your granddad
that's okay I appreciate that thank you
were you close to him
I wasn't super close
um we uh it kind of got muffled uh two
months prior to that uh my mom had
passed and so it was kind of just this
whole time of it we didn't really know
how to like cope with any of it because
things just happened so fast and so it
kind of got buried along with the rest
of uh the way life is going but we're
doing really good now so yeah married
got a house lost mom lost Grandpa all in
one year
yeah it's been a big deal here it's been
a big year off the back end of this
little thing called covid yeah wow yeah
yeah you guys are you guys are strong
good for you proud of you thank you um
okay so what how much is your balance on
your mortgage
the house we bought was for 530 000
um and uh we did we did it through an
FHA loan we did it through a 30-year
mortgage
um and our mortgage payment right now
what is the balance on your mortgage it
would be about 500 000. okay and what do
you make what's your household income
yeah so I'm between my wife and I I work
in sales she works in um kind of the
medical field we uh pull in about 120
000 between the two of us good for you
okay
the shortest distance between where you
are and wealth is to be debt free and
begin your long-term investing okay and
so you are debt free except the house
did I understand that correctly
correct yeah good and uh do you have any
any money in savings at all
right now we put down her down payment
about a week ago yeah okay so you need a
fully funded emergency fund you don't
have one
that is three to six months of your
household expenses
okay in your case that's probably 20
grand
so we're going to use some of that money
to round that out and then I want you to
be uh
resetting your budget and paying your
30-year mortgage like it's a 15.
okay and then I want you to start
putting 15 of your income into
retirement in 401ks Roth IRAs Roth 401ks
whatever you got available to you in
good growth stock mutual funds that's
baby steps one two three and four you
don't have kids yet or you would have
already told me and
um so baby step five is kids college we
don't have to deal with that today you
will in the future uh and then baby step
six and if you follow these baby steps
it's the shortest distance to wealth
that's why I'm always going to take you
there
okay and this is and where the money
comes from doesn't change it it's still
the shortest distance if you've got a
Bonus at work of 120 it's the same thing
as getting an inheritance of 120. it's
just got different emotions around it
but the application of it mathematically
to cause you to become wealthy goes in
exactly the same place and so we're
gonna we're gonna lead you towards
paying off your house next and so we're
going to set us out about 20 of this for
your emergency fund and some small
miscellaneous spending around the house
that you pay cash for if you need to
move up in car or anything like that you
pay cash for it and then the remaining
amount roughly a hundred thousand
dollars is going to go towards this
mortgage and reduce your mortgage and
then I want you to pay that mortgage off
in about the next four or five years pay
it off
translation you'll be 27 with a paid for
by then house worth seven hundred
thousand dollars translation you're
going to be a millionaire before you're
30 if you do what I freaking tell you to
do
okay but if you go screwing around with
what your broke friends tell you to do
you're going to end up with none of this
yeah but you're not because you're the
guy you're this kid's sharp oh yeah it's
the right but he's on the he's like game
on man that's right and what you've laid
out in the baby steps is for everybody
who's new to the program and you're
hearing these things this is just a
clear path as Davis talked about it for
years it's I can see this step then the
next step and the next step and that's
the huge breakthrough for folks when
they realize wait a second I can walk
this through and I'm going to get there
but you start taking advice and
strategies from other people who are
broke you get thrown off the path this
path those baby steps work no matter
what life throws at you and that's the
key and he's going to be a millionaire
oh if he does this and he and then he's
you know and by the way if you're a
millionaire when you're 30 do you know
what you're worth when you're 50 10 yeah
you know what you're worth when you're
70. 25. that's right million dollars
that's right
and you know so let's get the house paid
off and use all of those house payments
for Building Wealth keep your income
going up during that time always be
managing your money always be enjoying
your money always be giving your money
and always be investing your money and
by the way we've talked a lot about kids
in this hour
so always be teaching them to work
age appropriately gently when they're
four not so gently when they're 14.
that's right teach them to work teach
them to save
teach them to give
to be of service to the community to be
a giver to be unbelievably generous
and teach them to spend and enjoy their
money
most people in America know how to do
one of those four things spend right and
they're called congressmen
they don't work no
you're right about that if you if you
paid attention to the Congressional
schedule it would blow your mind it
would make a lot of Voters angry if they
saw people that work for them oh yeah
and staffers are doing the work they
show up for the vote
good friends that are congressmen except
for days friends yeah they're like Dave
would you please stop staring us out I'm
like hey you you enjoyed the club you
got elected right I mean I can't how
does that take how do I get the
crosshairs off of you I can't help you
with that Guild blessings you signed up
for this trip man all the Congress jokes
work we have to keep using them this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting for the pods for
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth
do work
that they love
create actual
amazing relationships Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author host of the Ken Coleman show is
my co-host today thank you for joining
us America triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number
Christian is calling from Los Angeles to
start this hour hi Christian welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi thanks for having me sure what's up
I have a career question
um relating to working in a family
business
um I'm graduating college in December
and I feel a lot of pressure from my
family to stay in the family business
but I'm not sure that that's the best
path for me especially since I have like
big goals of starting a family next year
or getting married more specifically and
moving out I just don't think that it
would be the right move and so I was
wondering if you had any advice on
navigating that conversation
well what has happened so far I'm
curious to know what's been said so far
anything at all or if you just kind of
swept it under the rug
no there's definitely been something
said like
um I've had conversations with my dad
about what I want to do and he seems to
have an understanding of it but my
grandmother has said things as far as
like we're gonna buy you out and like
we're gonna we're gonna make we're gonna
make you stay like you're not gonna
refuse it and so
um it's kind of like that kind of
pressure that kind of worries me of what
it would look like so dad's okay he
certainly understands the direction you
want to go but grandmother's she's
rattling the saber a little bit
right and I think it has something to do
with
um I am graduating college debt free
from a Christian University which is
pretty unheard of rare but they paid for
about a third to a half of my education
I paid for the other half and so
um maybe it has something to do with
that but I'm not sure well I see that's
dangerous uh to to be assuming things
like that especially with your parents
and your grandmother the question is is
do you know what you want to do long
term and why yes or no
um yeah I I really love doing sales and
I've been able to do some sales inside
of the company
um and I would love to do that long term
but I would not be able to have a or
afford the life that I want to have by
staying with the company
um well so here's you have to decide
what life do you want to live and you're
going to have to be okay disappointing
some people on this journey and that
doesn't mean you're a jerk doesn't mean
you're twerp it just means I want to go
this direction this is why I want to go
this direction I understand that you
want me here but I don't want to be a
part of the family business and you tell
them as clearly as you can why but you
don't justify it and you're respectful
and you go lead the life you want to
live because I'm going to tell you
something if you don't do what you want
to do and you do what they want to do
this is a recipe for a lot of bitterness
right what's your name what's your
degree in
marketing okay and you want to go into
sales and marketing
correct but your grandmother said that
she's going to give you so much money
that you can't refuse it but on the
other hand you said there wasn't enough
money working for the family business
I'm confused
yeah I I am too I I know what they would
be or I guess I'm just assuming that I
would know what they would be offering
me and we would have that conversation
once I get closer to graduating I
graduate in December but okay so what do
you think you can make going for work
for someone else
uh and starting off I think starting off
I think their salary would be
competitive with what I could make
around like 70. so you think you can
make 70 working somewhere else
correct and I think that they could
offer me that I just don't think there's
room for gross here why
because it's a small business
sales go make it a large business
I think there's something deep thought
you were a sales stud
yeah I mean I don't think you want it
worked out Valerie Christian I don't
think you want to work there and I think
this is a logical excuse that you're
making that is wrong validate why you
don't want to work for them but I think
there's something deeper am I right
um yeah I think you don't want the main
you don't have to control do you
yeah it's I work in the same office as
my dad so I think that's what you have
to acknowledge
yeah this hasn't got anything to do with
the job or the opportunity it's got to
do with the family Dynamic that you
don't want a long-term engage in you
want to go be your own guy yeah and that
doesn't that doesn't make you bad it
doesn't even make them bad
yeah okay
I've got family members that I love that
don't work here I've got family members
that I love that do work here and I love
both of them but that's the family
Dynamic that's not the job
yeah yeah I think it's always been a
struggle with having them have a say in
what I'm doing in like my career my life
decisions and so I think a branch off
from that is kind of what I'm looking
for yeah I think you're gonna you you
don't think you're gonna feel good about
yourself being continued you think your
dad's going to use his dad voice
when he's at work
yeah I mean no it's pretty separate as
far as that it's more so my grandma like
I said I can tell yeah yeah the Iron
Maiden back there you know yes I respect
her beyond belief she's the only uh
first she's giving me all my Christian
values no one else in my family's
Christian and so I think that's a that's
another part of it
um navigating that yeah Christian let me
tell you something let me tell you
something and I'm speaking from my own
experience and my own family Dynamic you
will eventually disrespect her
if you stay in the situation and she
runs over you and all this tension
that's underneath the surface I'm just
telling you yeah you will you can
respect what she has done to get here
and not respect how she would handle you
right and those are two different things
that's that's they're not mutually and I
think the respect stays intact Dave if
he decides to have a boundary there
Christian you've already decided where
not to work there quit calling it that
the job is bad just say what it is and
just go you know I'm just not
comfortable I think I need to go make my
own way I'm going to feel better about
me and that's the truth it's not that
the job is limited because you're going
into sales just go sell more
if you want to make more go sell more I
mean that's you know you know the job's
not limited it's you're limited but you
what you don't want to do is you don't
be an office next to your dad you
chuckled after you said it you don't
want to deal with your grandmother's
overbearing personality you said it
three times in the conversation in
different ways and so and that's okay
you can still love them not saying that
horrible people you just don't want to
work for them or with them and so go do
something else yeah you need to do that
for you and just for your own dignity
and um that that's the thing Ken one of
the things we've discovered at Ramsey
and we've discovered is we've worked
with small businesses all across America
and entree leadership is a high
percentage of small businesses are
family businesses by the way privately
held and they usually have multiple
family members working in them it's not
unusual at all and they're only the the
family business portion of the business
is only as functional as the family is
that's right if the family's cray-cray
at home they're going to be cray-cray at
work I mean it's pretty simple you guys
and if they're if they got control
issues at home and you know overbearing
and controlling and overreaching then
they're going to be that way at work and
I would say Christian go go Forge your
own path but don't act like it's never
because you may see the Dynamics change
where you could come back and be a part
of the family business down the road
when some of those Dynamics change who
knows a different version of you a
different version of them evolves that's
possible because you didn't say anything
negative about their character no so
that's good you're in you're in good
shape there yeah I think for now I think
you've already made your decision just
be kind about it and gentle and vague
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
whether one
they're watching guarantee and
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to save up to
40 percent off everything site-wide go
to blinds.com for more information
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by Dave Ramsey in studio
we're here for you this hour uh so Dave
uh recent headlines say that it might
take three months to land a new job in
this new wave of layoffs uh but I
believe that you can beat that I don't
think that data is right I think that
you can land a better job a lot quicker
given the demand that there is in the
marketplace but you've got to know what
to do and how to do it and a lot of Dave
comes down to one thing and as I've
taken calls on the Ken Coleman show here
on the Ramsey Show for years it comes
down to confidence how do you get
confidence to step out to make a pivot
to not let a layoff throw you off
especially while you're in the baby
steps and the answer to that is Extreme
Clarity to know who you are to know what
you want to do where you can do it so
that you have the confidence to never
let the economy inflation anything
coming your way throw you off and so
we're gonna talk through that formula in
my new event called career breakthrough
and our first one launches in just less
than a month here just a few weeks away
April 20th in Kansas City Missouri and
you've been we're going to be speaking
but I'm also be taking questions live
from the crowd and you've been at
Building Wealth when we John deloney and
I take questions live from the crowd
something special happens when people
are in a room like that it's like
freaking group therapy
I mean you you read their mail and
everybody else in the room needed to
hear what you said to that guy you know
what you said to that girl you
encouraged her uh you said okay you you
know you you don't believe in yourself
as much as everybody else in the room
believes in you I've watched you do that
and all of a sudden their body language
changes they they swell up with like I
can do this they start to believe or
they're they're being just cray-cray and
you just call them out go hey hey hey
don't do that right you know because
you're a truth teller man I mean it's
fun to watch you do this with these guys
and unfold it so if if you really need
to know exactly what your next steps are
Ken can tell you and you need to be at
one of these events whether you think
you're losing your job whether you've
already quit your job whether you uh
just hate your job whatever it is you
want to increase your income you want to
go do something you love and you hate
what you're doing now all of these
things Kansas City April 20th just a
couple of weeks from now and then
Chicago May 16th Atlanta uh May 18th in
Dallas Texas uh May 23rd it's only 50
dollars dollars you paid that for a
pizza
so uh get today's inflation
dmcsolutions.com events get this done
because here's what you need sometimes
sometimes you need someone to say out
loud what way down inside you are
already know is true
um you really you're kind of like me you
you don't really say anything that
people don't already know no not at all
no it's exactly right all we do is
uncover it and they're looking for
permission to say what you're already
thinking and we've gotten really good at
it why is there a fear Dave between from
people who are uh they're trying to get
out of debt they're in the baby steps
and they hear that you can make more
money if you get a better job they hear
that the side job economy is great they
hear that freelancing's there but it
feels kind of scary to step into
something else because they're they're
in that gazelle intensity what's what's
the reason behind that fear because
that's what we confronted yeah um
whether you're doing the baby steps or
not I I think it's just human nature uh
we all have a negative a black cloud a
black dog Churchill called it uh that
that you know that comes over you it's
the same one that says okay I'm gonna
get laid off automatically what do
people think my next job I'm gonna make
less yep instead of like oh God I'm
finally free from these people I can go
make more yeah because the number of
times you go from 60 to 80 000 a year or
from 80 to 120 in a new job is not
that's It's Not Unusual at all that's
right because a lot of times you're more
valuable than they've been able to or
were willing to pay you that's right at
the other place and you just hadn't
tested the waters in the marketplace you
go
dang that's exactly right and that's
what we're covering at this event by the
way we're going to give you the courage
based on confidence to walk forward and
Get It Go Get It this is a great economy
to make money right now but we
understand there's fear and doubt so
ramseysolutions.com events uh you get
the tickets there I always think about
the old uh motivational guys back in the
day you know they would say things like
if you if money wasn't an issue if you
had all the money you needed right
and no one would tell you no
what would you do oh the answer comes
quick yeah everybody always has a quick
answer when you remember the other one
the other one oh motivational thing I
remember this clearly a guy said this he
was talking about doing sales calls but
it also involves you know what you know
what a sales call is it's called an
interview when you're looking for a job
right you're trying to make a sale yeah
only you're the dadgum product right so
but he said you know he paints this
whole thing out about a sales guy going
to fly into New York City to make the
sale
and as he when he lands his wife calls
and says we just won I just got a letter
that that we've that we got an
inheritance of two million dollars
and he goes I don't even have to go make
the sale
but I'm already up here I might as well
go right so he kind of swaggers in acts
like he doesn't care because he doesn't
talks to them clearly was kind to them
but talk to them about the benefits of
the product but was very overly
confident not arrogant but just didn't
have to make the sale right smell
different you know yeah starving sales
people smell bad and and so they got a
smell on them we got a stink on you man
you know that's right you smell like a
loser that's right you got the smell on
you and so he walks in there makes the
sale
goes back to the hotel room his wife
calls and says God they made a huge
mistake it was the next door neighbor
that got the letter not us oh
that is fair but I mean what's the
difference the only difference is your
mindset everything it was a complete
mindset between years the sale was still
the sale the client was still the
clients the interview was still the
interview the job hire was still the job
higher the only difference was he didn't
think he had to do it and so he walked
in there with complete different vocal
cord tenseness yes his voice was deeper
not high pitched when you get scared you
get high-pitched you know I know that's
what I said you know yeah but I mean
when you get scared everybody does your
vocal your octaves go up and your your
body language changes and you're you're
weird and you know fear does weird you
know yes when you're desperate you can
people can smell it oh for sure and they
don't want to hire you no not at all
that's exactly right so it really is
about confidence and and you get
confidence in one place folks extreme
Clarity we see people catch this in the
baby steps when they see the clear path
they go oh I can get out of debt and
they become confident there's a clear
there's a clear path to go getting a job
right that's right welcome to it
absolutely well so here's the deal you
got to know what you want and you got to
know if you can actually do it so the
the the the the stress for people is I
think I want this but I don't know if I
can actually pull it off so what we
start with is marrying those two things
we call it getting clear this is what I
want to do do I have what it takes to do
it in other words do I have the talent
where I can go get the skill and
experience that changes the mindset now
it's possible yeah and so then we go to
we go next we go all right what is it I
have to do to get qualified from an
experienced skill set and then we go who
are the people I need to know
connections are everything that bring
opportunities to us and so when you
understand that your entire physiology
changes like you were saying in that
story I now know what I want to do I
know where I want to do it and I know
how to get there that takes a person
from being uh timid and doubtful to
clear bold and courageous and that's how
you get what you want that's how you get
out of debt that's how you launch and
start a business and grow it that's how
you parent that's how you win in your
relationship it comes down to do I know
who I want to be and why and how to get
there even kids and dogs can smell fear
oh for sure yeah they know it yeah they
know it we need more coffee I know they
got your money but it comes from having
a plan knowing who you are being
comfortable on your own skin and not
that guy you know what he he had a I
don't care
right he had a confidence he I don't
have to get this no I don't have to get
this it's all it's all don't sweat the
small stuff and it's all yes small stuff
it is all right Bradley's with us in
Cincinnati hey Bradley what's up
hey thanks for taking my call appreciate
it sure how can we help
so
um went through uh bunch of Peace
University last year late last year and
got all that done
um
and we're working on our budget and uh
unfortunately my father has uh dementia
and so does her mother and so we're
trying to do the best we can with that
right now my wife has had to go to
part-time
um that she felt she needed to do that
how can we help right quick for a run
out of time so anyway
um we what's your question where she's
putting 15 into
um for her retirement that she's late to
the game so I help her get there but
what I noticed through some calculations
I ran on her paycheck the other day was
that it's almost that she's about 22
okay you know you need to be at 15 or
less if you need to stop temporarily
while you guys fight through some of
these bad times you're going through
that's okay but long term 15 of your
household income going into somebody's
retirement
foreign
[Music]
a home is one of the biggest decisions
of your life you need a partner like
Churchill Mortgage Churchill is one of
the highest rated lenders in the country
and their Ramsay trusted because they do
what's right for you Churchill works
with you to build a mortgage the Ramsay
way one that doesn't bust your budget
sets you up for financial success and
helps you get out of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America
join us anytime you'd like in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions we do the show from
one to four central time every day five
days a week and we're on the glass in
the lobby uh Dr John deloney does his
show on the glass in the lobby and the
Ken Coleman show is done on the glass in
the lobby so there's stuff going on all
day long around here but from one to
four we're here live free homemade
chocolate chip cookies cooked daily
and uh coffee and other goodies in the
bakery the Baker Street Bakery over here
great pastries as well yes good stuff
coming it's all all free to our guests
and a great Lobby experience where you
get to see some of the history of Ramsey
and all those kinds of things and so uh
and then folks sit around watch the show
there's usually 50 to 200 sitting out
here something like that and the debt
free stage is here and on the debt free
stage are Aaron and Jill hi Aaron how
are you guys good how are you welcome
where do you live Council Bluffs Iowa
Bon welcome to Nashville how much debt
have you paid off a little over 253
thousand dollars love it and uh how long
did this take a little over seven years
okay and your range of income during
that time when we first started it was
right around 80 000
um now it's around 150. okay cool and
what kind of debt was the 253. that was
our home student loans Vehicles credit
cards completely debt free housing
everything
all how old are you two weird people I'm
40. 37. and you're paid for house yes
that's worth how much right now roughly
000. cool how much have you got in
retirement so I have a pension through
my work
um so that's I can actually retire in
about four and a half years then
everything else on the side roughly a
little over probably 150 000. Okay cool
so you're about a half million net worth
give or take way to go you're on your
way to being a millionaire yes very good
good for you guys well done well done so
tell us your story what happened here
so in 2013
she gave birth to our daughter our
middle child and then she became a
stay-at-home mom
and after she became a stay-at-home mom
her student loans kicked in which was
500 bucks a month so we realized at that
point in time how broke we were and we
couldn't even buy groceries kind of buy
the gas we were a negative a thousand
dollars a month just in our bills and
that doesn't even count groceries food
nothing like that so I just started
working crazy hours and I picked up
every Moon Lighting position I can get
I'm a police officer so I picked up
every security job out there overtime
you name it and I was never home and so
she was pretty much a single parent
raising our kids and I just worked
non-stop in about I did that for about
two years and I was like I just can't
keep up with this pace
it's killing us and so I got introduced
to you through uh actually one of our
lieutenants that's recently retired a
Millionaire on our department has been
following you for years so he introduced
me to you and I just we jumped All In
okay so you you were you were working
your tail off but you're spinning your
wheels I was spinning I had no plans no
no Rhyme or Reason or nothing it was
just a revolving door yes wow wow so
Jill you're at home with all these
little kids how scared were you
uh it was intense yeah there was a lot
of kids and then worrying about him on
the streets
um
yeah I do want to say thank you for how
you serve oh thank you I appreciate the
community you put your life on the line
and uh that's that's impressive stuff
and and it should be uh called out but I
want to ask you so you hear about Dave
and you've been working crazy hours as
you're at this point you're going I
can't do this anymore then you find out
I still got to work gazelle and tits so
I'm just curious what was the transition
after you start to hear about the baby
steps and you're freeing at both ends
because of all the hours what'd you do
next
so we had a we knew a y at that point
and before I there was no light at the
end of the tunnel it's just I'm just
paying the bills and this is never going
to end we have no we have no way out at
this point and once I stumbled upon Dave
Ramsey
um now we had a purpose we we had an out
and people standing on the stage a lot a
lot of days working you know 17 20 hour
days that's helped me got through the
process and uh
so we gave all the credit and thanks in
the world to you Dave well I'll go to
you you did it when you hear that gum
Heroes I just showed you how so you kept
sitting over here warm and dry you're
out there in the rain right yes so I
kept that up for we reached we had all
our Consumer Debt was about 77 78 000
and so we got that paid off in 19 and a
half months because we went crazy I paid
my truck off sold that went and got a
beater car that I drove for about three
years until it blew up on me on the
interstate and and uh we got everything
paid off except our uh except our house
in about 19 and a half months and which
allowed me to take a new position on an
apartment
um Department being a Academy instructor
so which was Monday through Friday
weekends off and so I I got my family
back we saved our marriage and uh your
family got you back yes yes yes
wow and then you could just go steady
and chip away and it was totally rather
than going different yeah so we probably
would have got our house paid off
if I kept that same Pace up for probably
a little under 36 months so it actually
prolonged it um taking this new position
so what yeah that's what you're supposed
to do about yourself three four maybe
step four five six you're supposed to be
intentional not intense yes and that's
what you did you were intentional well
done I mean in seven years you're not 40
and your dad gum house is paid off shut
up okay this is all right way to go man
yeah way to go what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is
don't talk about it be about it we we
deal with a lot of our friends and we
started this plan at the same time
um we actually went through with it we
dedicated our lives and a part of that's
because we had to we didn't have a
choice
um sacrifice this big time sacrifice
yeah I I mean my wife was a stay-home
mom for years and she was a single
parent pretty much because I was always
at work and
um it's just working together to get
this done yeah be about it don't talk
about it Jill what do you tell people
the key is
oh that's uh
mainly being a support for
for the process and
gosh I don't even I don't even know the
whole process is was a blur you know
you're going through it and it's you
have all the kids at home and you're
just you're trying to chip away at the
same thing and it feels it feels a lot
yeah it was a lot for was it worth it
I think now yes because
to
travel with the kids now which is what
we really wanted to do give them
experiences yeah absolutely so I would
say now yes if you're if you ask me
during the process I would say no yeah
because you're hanging on by three yeah
19 months of of doing this with great
intensity of hell yeah yeah and then
after that you had another five years of
just intentional plotting and seven
years later your house is paid off and
everything correct yeah yeah so the
hardest part was the 19. yeah yeah
absolutely yeah because he was gone all
the time yeah working all sorts of
shifts so that's what Sharon Ramsey
would tell you she said she was a single
mom for a period of time there yeah yeah
because she was a she's a work Widow
because we didn't have a choice yep
that's exactly us we didn't we didn't
have a choice so you look at me now you
know so there we go exactly it worked
out darling it did yeah that's what yeah
we laugh about that all the time we
drove through an old neighborhood that
we used to live in last night on the way
home uh from a thing we've been on and
we're like yeah
um have these houses gone down or have
we gotten a snobby
during this process I actually took your
uh Financial Master coaching training
yeah because we actually started telling
our friends about this process or
listening to them kind of in their
concerns and we showed them what we did
so we kind of stumbled upon become what
coaches ourselves and so we've been
doing this for about two years coaching
people and uh so far to this date we've
helped pay off including our own debt
over a million dollars
all right it's Aaron Jill kale Kaden
Kinley and Brooks from Council Bluffs
Iowa all right house and everything 253
000 paid off in seven years count it
down let's hear a debt free scream in
three two one
yeah
that's great
man that's some hard work that are going
on yes got it done get her done are you
about it don't talk about it this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Randy is with us in
Pensacola hi Randy welcome to the Ramsay
show
hello Dave how are you doing today
better than I deserve what's up
so am I hey so um today I just paid off
my house whoa yeah to go
thank you sir thank you very much and
it's all it's all thanks to you
um and the teachings that you've uh that
you've provided throughout the years uh
I also turned 63 today too so it was a
it was a birthday gift happy birthday
what's the house worth Randy
uh sitting right now at 4 30. excellent
how much you got in retirement
uh about
350. okay cool we got other assets
well yeah of course I've got you know I
got three cars and and whatnot so I'm
getting close yeah you're almost to that
millionaire way to go man I'm I'm almost
there man thank you very much and that's
all it's all thanks to you I didn't know
what you did it you're the hero man way
to go
hey so the question that I have today is
mistakingly I opened up a Roth about six
months ago and started putting and
adjusted my 401k uh Investments to bring
it down to the match and then putting
everything else into the Roth okay
um then I found out that I I guess I
need to keep the money in the rock for
five years or so I'm not sure if that's
true or not but I'm trying to figure out
at one point if at all do I start
pulling out of the 401K and moving to a
Roth or some other Avenue if that makes
sense
okay
um number one you're still working and
you're still contributing and now you're
contributing to a Roth 401k with a match
is that correct
Roth in addition to a 401k okay your
401k does not offer Roth option
correct correct so I've got a sure I've
got opened up through a different broker
are you sure your your 401k won't allow
you to do Roth most of them do now
well yes yes yes
it does okay so there's two separate
issues okay there's the issue of what
you put in from this point forward and
there's the issue of what's already in
there what's already in there's 350 000
in traditional right
correct okay and then from this point
forward I would do everything as Roth
you have a mandatory drawdown called the
required minimum distribution that now
doesn't hit until you're 73 and you can
pull that from traditional
uh you're gonna have to start pulling it
out at 73 anyway even if you don't want
to on the traditional you do not have a
mandatory required or required minimum
distribution any mandatory withdrawals
on Roth portions so I'm going to do the
Roth and let the Roth just grow and grow
and grow and grow and grow tax-free I
would draw down for living at retirement
on the traditional First
before I draw down on the Roth
okay now but from this point forward
here's what's going to happen you do
your individual Roth IRAs you make your
401k a 401K Roth for future
contributions not the past ones
you follow me okay yes sir now they the
matching Portion by regulation by law
has to be in traditional so the part
that they put in is going to continue to
be traditional also
so you're going to have the 350 that's
traditional and stays there plus the
matching portion from this point forward
is going to be traditional then you're
going to have whatever you put into your
Roth individual and whatever you put
into your 401k that's going to be Roth
from this point forward so you've got a
lot of different things going on here
and then when you reach the point that
you actually are going to need to use
some of the money you would use some of
the 350 or whatever it is grown to if
it's invested in good growth stock
mutual funds in seven years when you're
70 it should be 700.
yes sir I'm looking forward to that and
I'm as a matter of fact I have an
appointment I have another appointment
with a uh
financial planner here next week okay
well make sure you're checking with one
of our smart investor Pros okay
absolutely yes sir yeah and get just sit
down with someone with the heart of a
teacher they can explain why I'm saying
this and then once you see that you're
going to go oh I get it I'll see what
Dave's doing now but the tax-free growth
of the Roth uh you're going to put that
off indefinitely you may never use it it
may just be an inheritance to someone
and when it is it's a tax-free
inheritance to someone
that's why I want you to keep your hands
off of it because it's very likely that
the seven the 300 growing to 700 and you
know just watching your budget you're
probably going to live on that money
before you ever get into the other money
and you may very well never get into
that of the money it may grow and be
left as a tax-free inheritance where if
you leave a traditional as an IRA or as
a inherited IRA it becomes inherent it
becomes taxable as you're as you're not
as an inheritance tax but as your income
tax as your heirs pull it out a lot
going on there but way to go Randy yeah
pays his house off and it's his birthday
that's a good day Mikhail is with us in
Knoxville hey Mikhail welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey Dave thanks for having me sure
what's up
uh so yeah my wife and I Dave we just
started uh doing the baby steps and you
know we're looking over our budget and
I'm just wondering I'm kind of convicted
about like ties uh like our ties is our
third biggest uh Bill if you will I'm
just wondering if we pause that to you
know get out of debt and then
pick it up later or just you know
struggle with how to deal with that
you don't have many bills
uh yeah I guess I mean that's one you
got a lot of little bitty ones
uh well I have my I have rent and then
car
uh student loans uh
okay well you used some key words that
I'm going to make sure I understood what
you meant but I think I know because I
think it's Tribal speaking I know what
you're talking about I'm convicted
and you use the word tithe this is
Christian lingo okay agreed
yes sir okay so Evangelical Christians
like you and me uh believe and teach
that the Bible says to give a tenth of
our income to our local church
all right as a beginning point in our
generosity and in Proverbs it says
multiple times that the tithe is first
fruits which Proverbs is written in a to
an agrarian economy first fruits
literally means the first fruit that you
pick out of the orchard the first Lambs
that are born to the flock every year
the first one tenth is Holy and set
aside unto the Lord
and so your giving comes off the top in
other words before you do anything
10 now having said all of that that's
exactly what I do and I have done for 40
years that I've been walking with God
I absolutely have never done it because
a I thought God owed me something if I
did
in other words I was giving so that he
had to give something back to me that's
not how this works and I have never
given ever because I thought it was like
a law and I was keeping the law
I gave because I love God he's been
really good to me and he my loving
heavenly father says son the best way to
live your life is to be generous and
here's your starting point
and generous people have better lives
than selfish people and here's your
starting point and I give from that
Spirit not from a spirit of I'm trying
to keep somebody's rules
okay yes sir so convicted ich
I mean I get the I get what you mean
your heart is being tugged you've been
taught the giving matters and you want
to stick to what you've been taught
that's what you're saying when you say
convicted but convicted is what you do
with a crime so I'm probably not going
to go there I'm probably just going to
say as an act of love and as an act of
believing that my heavenly father who
teaches me to give is going to give me a
better is going to cause me to have a
better life if I'm a generous person I'm
going to give out of that that's also
why I over tip
yes sir you do want to wait on my table
yes sir
and and remember you were taught this so
you understand and we don't want to
leave a bunch of people out here and do
too much Christian ease but it's it's
considered the first fruits right you
understand that so you got to adjust
everything else don't adjust the tithe
just everything else if you get out of
it a little bit slower because you're
doing this yeah you're gonna be okay but
here's the weird thing
generous people are much more attractive
they tend to get more raises they tend
to get more promotions because who wants
to promote a selfish jerk
oh my gosh
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships the
work Ramsay personality Ken Coleman is
with me today he talks to you about
getting work you love and doing jobs
that matter doing a career that matters
if you want to use that word and hey
we're here to talk to you about your
life and your money it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Ken takes calls on the Ken Coleman
show every day broadcast is a podcast 75
radio stations and of course SiriusXM as
well and joins me a couple times a week
here or there on this show so thanks for
being here boys and girls we're glad
you're here triple eight eight two five
five two two five Bert is in Wichita hi
Bert how are you
I'm doing well sir how are you better
than I deserve what's up
well sir I had a question for you guys
um we adopted a little girl with special
needs here over a year ago
and during that time I was able to find
a job that I'd been looking for and
really really wanted and uh now we're
six months into this new position and uh
this little girl we adopted needs a lot
more medical attention and my wife is
talking about wanting to move to a
larger City where we could get some
better quality specialists in healthcare
and I just I feel
um I'm struggling with it trying to
figure out you know if this would be a
smart move or or not and it you know
especially because of the job I just
started it and it's something that I've
really wanted for a long time yeah
that's pretty heavy how far away is the
city where the medical uh opportunities
are better
it would be
what she's currently talking about is
about three and a half four hour drive
yeah and we go there for appointments
you know right now it you know on a
weekly to two week basis so you know it
requires us to have some extra planning
take time off work and uh for her job
and mine you know depending on who goes
with her and uh
it's just I see the logic and her idea
of wanting to move it just I I'm
struggling with it because of work the
position of my I'm in yeah because you
let's so let's remove this unique
challenge of your daughter's very
important medical care you're on the
ladder that you want to be on I'm
guessing that you feel like this is
going to take you somewhere where you
want to go or you're actually there now
is that is that the case
yeah I'm kind of there now yeah so this
is what do you do yeah
so I uh I worked in agriculture I'm a
district sales manager for a seed
company
right now yeah and this is this is
pretty high up the ladder for you or the
top of the ladder where you want to be
well it's maybe not the top but it's a
position that I've strived to get and
you know it took a long time to find it
and get there right so so the first
thing I would be doing if I'm in your
shoes
um is I want to at least look at at this
city three and a half four hours away
and I want to see in my industry what
kind of opportunities are there because
you've got a very unique narrative to
where you're not a flake if you were to
leave this company uh six months in so
in the narrative from leaving them and
what it looks like on your professional
record or resume plus joining another
company it's a really unique
circumstance so I want to at least see
what my options are I want to totally
exhaust that to see that now if it
doesn't feel right I'm also sitting down
with my wife in the situation going okay
she needs this medical care we need to
find some other ways to where I'm not
having to take a lot of time off
um and and we're going to make some
adjustments in our life so that I can
stay put and keep growing professionally
and take care of the responsibilities
I've got to take care of and so I'm just
find some other ways some support
systems to be able to make that drive
and do that but I'm not going to pull up
Roots unless I can replace my income and
my professional opportunity that's that
would be my position however let me just
say this at the end of the day you have
to do what's best for your family and if
this is a season of life where maybe you
have to make some sacrifices that made
me be the decision you've got to make
too I don't think this is clear-cut
um what is the nature of your daughter's
disabilities
well so when we adopted we knew she had
cerebral palsy and epilepsy
um but when we got her back we adopted
her from Colombia
and uh
we didn't we asked all the questions we
possibly could but they couldn't or
didn't know or wouldn't fill us in on
everything
so she's just she's got a rare form of
flesc's Linux Gusto syndrome and it's
degenerative is what we found out so and
she just needs a lot more you know
almost 24 hour care than what we can
give her in the little small town that
we're at right now
um
you know how old is she huh
she is uh she just turned nine right now
and how long have you all had her you
said two years
well uh we've had her for about a year
it's taken almost two two and a half
years to get yeah how how old are you
here
I am 42 40 yeah I think I'm 42. I forgot
yes it's all running together I don't
blame it I don't blame you so here's
what here's what I have learned by
having Dr John deloney sitting next to
me on this seat for a couple of years
now I'm gonna I'm gonna Channel my best
deloney for a second okay
um he says that you had a picture
of what this adoption was going to
represent that there were some
challenges but they were doable
that picture has been shattered
the challenges are greater than you
thought
a lot greater than you thought
and so grieving
that picture that you thought you had of
this adopting this sweet kid
giving her a cool start here being able
to take her out of the mess that she was
in and everything was going to be okay
and you were going to work through the
challenges then take the challenges and
and 2xm or 3x them and now you've got a
A Broken Heart
about the picture that you had that's
what he would say does that sound right
yes sir that sounds pretty close to
exactly right yeah and and then that
goes with you know okay and I just got
this job yeah oh man I've been wanting
this job and so now I'm grieving that
and yet you're the kind of guy I can
tell by talking to you for just a few
minutes you're going to do what it takes
take care of this baby
you're really not arguing with your wife
it's just making you mad at
life you know
yeah yeah you know because you're you're
a guy who's going to do what it takes to
take care of his family so that's not in
question now I think Ken's right
um
what I would do is before I just
completely go this whole thing's blown
up it's not gonna you know everything
you might make six phone calls in the
other city and land a very similar
position you don't know that yet I don't
know that yet because you hadn't tried
yet
right so I don't know that your dream
has to die where you are it might go to
the other place and flourish just as
well or something similar or that
scratches the itch that this scratches
but a slightly different industry yeah I
don't know whether you're in agriculture
in that area you know but you're within
30 minutes of the hospital instead of
four and a half hours
you're a good man Bert yeah you're a
good man you're going to do what's right
and it's going to be okay and in 10
years you're going to look back and
whatever you do will have been the right
thing because you're that guy
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsay personality is my
co-host today
thank you for joining us America and
more and more of you are whether it's
talk radio 680 talk radio stations where
the second largest Talk Radio Show in
America and have been for many years
thank you for that
uh TBN now carrying the show many of you
watching and joining us there for the
very first time thank you for that uh of
course SiriusXM and uh every version of
podcast out there whether it be apple or
number 15 in the world or 13 did we get
up to 13 in the world we got up to 13.
it bounces around we're in that range
yeah right in there and uh so uh thank
you for that and all of this happens
because of you guys because you share
the show you tell people where to listen
or where to watch the show big deal on
YouTube a billion downloads now wow a
billion downloads that's hard to get my
head around so thank you guys for all
that share the show if you're listening
uh share it you can do it by link or
just tell somebody where you're watching
or listening if you're listening on talk
radio you share it by saying hey I
listen to such and such a radio station
or click on the link to share it if
you're podcasting or youtubing or
whatever subscribe to the show if you're
in a in a digital setting where you can
click the Subscribe button that makes a
big difference and pushes the show out
in front of more and more and more
people and it's continuing our growth
and we appreciate the opportunity to
help more and more people because you
shared it because you subscribed and
because some of you left a five-star
rating one Stars aren't helpful mom said
if you hadn't got anything nice to say
don't say nothing at all
so just to go ahead and leave your five
star rating or just move right along and
do something else with your little time
okay but we need your help thank you for
all of that thank you very much hey the
spring wealth Building Wealth live tour
is almost over we got two more stops you
guys have given us sellouts in every
city thank you so much uh in exactly
three weeks you can join me George
Campbell Rachel Cruz and Jade warshaw in
Salt Lake City on April the 24th and
then our event in Anaheim California May
the second almost sold out don't want to
wait much longer those tickets are
almost gone and that's going to include
Ken Coleman to my right Dr John deloney
and Jade orshaw as well so you want to
come ready to go the venues are packed
get there early uh
get ready to change your life and get
you a good seat everybody's feeling the
effects of inflation and we're going to
walk you through Building Wealth in
America today in 2023 in this current
weird and wacky time that we live and it
still does work
every time
April 24th Salt Lake City Anaheim May
2nd tickets are 49 each and they're
going really fast go to
ramseysolutions.com
events all the VIP and platinum have
sold out months ago but the General
Admissions are still available and you
get there early to get you a good seat
Elaine Is With Us in Tulsa Oklahoma hi
Elaine
hi what's up
what I'm calling about is my my stepson
who whom I love as much as I do my own
son
we've been very close and uh he has come
to me for some money
a large sum this time and um
I just
don't know
if he's ever going to learn how to do
his money I I don't know what to do how
do you want to help him how old is he
62.
83 almost 84. wow
no no you sound like you're 44. yeah and
and I'm when I had a stepson I didn't
have 62 in my head okay
um so how much large sum is he asking
for
uh 69 000. for what
well he he gave me a list
of bills and um
or mortgage payments on his house and 10
acres and and mortgage payments on some
land and credit cards and student loans
and a Truck
okay if he's 22 I kind of get it
I'm having trouble wrapping my head
around how you're 62 and you still ask
Mommy for money
I'm really struggling with that what's
his problem does he not work much
he works all the time and his wife works
what do they do with all their money
I that's one question I did not ask him
um
and I should have when we sat down to
talk about this yeah you know what he's
going to say
I don't know
because he doesn't know he does not yeah
he has absolutely no plan because no one
plans to make a mess like he has made
sure yeah so how much money have uh how
how long have you been giving him money
oh uh
I've given me money ever since his dad
died but you know off on home but it's
been small amounts or twelve thousands
how long uh
in about nine years yeah okay
and how much money do you have hon
well my husband uh
and I loved him dearly he left me a
trust
and right now and it is 335 797.
uh I had Social Security
[Music]
so out of the trust I get uh monthly I
get 2 800 a month so where are you gonna
get sixty nine thousand dollars
well I'd have to take it out of this
this trust oh you could take it out of
the trust okay all right
so um and you're 82 and you are you in
ill health
well I'm 84. almost 84. you sound like
you're in great health
true and I've been diagnosed with severe
uh
degenerative so what happens to this
truck what happens to this what happens
to this trust when you pass
he gets it he gets it there's no your
own there's no other siblings or because
it was in his dad's name before
the other sibling
the estate and my home also you saw the
trust you're leaving to the the stepson
you don't have you said to your own so
you don't have a son well we went
through the court and we bought his
older brother out
uh but do you have any do you have any
children
why are they not getting part of the
trust
well because it was made out to
my husband's Sons okay all right because
it was his money again it was his money
and he wanted left through to them after
you passed I got you yeah okay and then
one of them's out because he tried to
miss it over I got you okay wow okay so
here here's what you can do
um I don't know if you will because
you're a very sweet lady and I don't
know if you're too sweet or not
I want you to be so sweet that you love
this 62 year old better than you have
loved him because by giving him money
you have not been loving him well you've
allowed him to continue to misbehave you
gave a drunk a drink
does that make sense
and you know that that's why you called
me that's why you call me because you
know that
oddly enough I'm his age and that's
weird okay that's so weird but anyway
yeah um so the the thing is anytime
you've got someone who's perpetually
coming to you for money and they
um
and you give them money and it doesn't
help them then you become and and nice
people or who does this not mean people
uh you become what we call an enabler
you're giving a drunk a drink
and so you've enabled him and he's
gotten Bolder and Bolder and Bolder as
he's gone along and so
um I'm AF here's what you say I talk to
my financial counselor because you did
I'm him
and he said I don't have enough money to
give you the 69 000 because you don't
you don't have that much money
you need the money that you have for the
for your life
now if there's money left over when
you're gone you can leave it to him
that's fine but you don't have 69 000 to
give him even if you did it wouldn't be
good for him it's not proven to be good
for him in the past
so what I would do is this I would offer
to help him as he goes through Financial
Peace University and I'm going to pay
for it and give it to you for free I'm
going to put you on hold and Austin's
going to give it to you to give to him
if he goes to the class and documents to
you that he pays off a bill you will
match him up to
what he pays off and so instead of 69
000 he's going to get 30 000 if he
changes his habits and pays bills off
and if he goes through this class if he
doesn't do those things he gets zero
until you die
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Coleman Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book paycheck
to purpose is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions all the debt free stage Bill
and Amy are with us hey guys how are you
good how are you we're doing great
thanks honored to have you where do you
live uh Folsom California okay which is
near Sacramento Sacramento gotcha okay
welcome to Nashville thank you good to
have you and how much debt have you paid
off a little over a hundred and twenty
two thousand good how long did that take
uh 43 months good for you and your range
of income during that time we start
started at 1 30 and ended up at 170.
cool what do you all do for a living
I work in a health administration and
and I work in the energy sector oh very
cool good to have you guys thanks all
right what kind of debt was the 122
000. oh well 80 000 was my student loan
and then we had a car loan and of course
credit card debt we were kind enough
very normal yeah just normal people yeah
and then you figured out normal sucks I
don't want to be normal anymore that's
very true yeah all right so tell us the
story what happened got you on this
Ramsey stuff uh well it happened back a
while ago in 2006 my husband worked in
the mortgage industry we had just bought
our first home and he lost his job of
course everything when the crash
happened so we tried to stay afloat as
much as possible we had our first son
Justin and we realized that we just we
couldn't make ends meet so we ended up
following bankruptcy and having to short
sell our home that was probably the most
humiliating thing we've ever had to go
through amen we went through that
um we've moved to an apartment had our
other son and tried to rebuild our life
bought a beautiful home in Folsom and
saw the same thing happening again oh
and we're like okay this can't happen
again I don't want to feel that we can't
disappoint our family and our kids and
we need to figure out how to do this
right so I asked my brother for help I
said hey you know he's always been
really good with money do you want to
sit with me can we figure out this
budget thing he's like well have you
heard Dave Ramsey and Financial Peace
University and I'm like no I haven't
he's like well let's start so wow we
bought the DVD set I brought home the
workbooks introduced you to my husband
and we literally went I mean zero to 60
in a matter of minutes we were ready
yeah we and we're sick and tired of
being sick exactly we now go to work for
ourselves and not for Capital One or
whoever we owed so it feels amazing and
so that was our huge turnaround for us
and we will never go back again so Bill
she comes home with these DVDs from her
brother
what did you say well at first when she
told me about the uh DV DVD set um she
was like you got to hear this guy Dan
Ramsey and I was like oh God here here
we go it's another one of those messages
and but once we started listening uh to
the discs it actually
um was common sense and it's uh stuff
that we grew up with going hey you know
I don't even know why we're not
following these principles and it wasn't
until then that we got together and
we're looking at our budgets
and that was a surprising moment too
because when we figured out how much we
were in debt really I mean because for
us we just wake up we were in the
routine we go to work we come back but
after all that long work you kind of
feel like you need to reward reward
yourself right so we went out there and
without even thought we're going out to
dinners we're just spending like crazy
so now looking at our budget and our
numbers and put it all in perspective
for us we're like oh my God we're just
we got to get and follow the baby steps
and um ever since then we've been
rocking it I did second jobs uh second
and third jobs and we pulled it through
and it was you know pretty hard work but
at the end of the day this was our goal
to be on the stage and to actually you
know just let everybody know if we can
do it anybody can do it you just got to
put in that effort the same period of
time that goes by for everybody else
where you're waking up in that routine
and you just don't know how to get out
we did that little extra work but at
least now we have a purpose of why we're
busting but to go out there and just
kill it because at the end of the whole
thing really now we're feeling the peace
Amy couldn't even sleep at night half
the time worrying about the bills you
know so now it's really nice to see her
just relax and life is totally different
so here's what I want people to hear
they heard you both say you worked
multiple jobs yeah so I want to know
what you did because this is the kind of
stuff that people need to hear because
you just simply said we are going to
work and I'm guessing you didn't have a
problem sleeping when you're working all
those extra jobs
no not at all tired yeah yeah so what
you both do give us those extra jobs so
I worked at a restaurant I worked a
Hostess job and
um I did I actually got tips I made so
much more money than he did in his
realtail job he's like I should have
done that I ended up getting a promotion
at the at the restaurant on a raise like
I was like this is not even my job like
this is just so I can get extra money
but it ended up being a lot of fun it
was a lot of work
um worked every single day for 60 hours
70 hours a week and it just was but it
was totally worth it what'd you do Bill
yeah I was working retail and then also
on the weekends when my friend needed
some help he owns his own electrical
business so he would call me build you
want to come out and work and we would
just go out and nail it so every little
bit of time and the thing is that we
supported each other so when she had to
go to work I would take care of the
house vice versa you know doing the
cooking taking care of the kids all that
but at the end of the day you know it
was all worth it and it's not forever no
that's right it was just until you get
done yeah and that's for free that's
what I wanted to ask how long before you
feel the emotional momentum of work in
those crazy hours you go okay but we're
at least knocking out with these debt
snowballs one at a time I mean how long
before you realize this is worth it the
biggest hurdle was a student loan
because it was so large it was great
doing the little ones we're like oh my
gosh we totally got this really got this
in the last year it was like okay we
just got to go full board and we just
worked work work and every time I made
that payment and saw it go down I'm like
oh my gosh it's even lower than it was
before and it was just it was that
momentum of we're almost there it's just
seeing the little pieces fall apart and
then get to the big one and then slowly
chip away at it that was very rewarding
very rewarding
how much of the 122 was the student loan
80 000 80. okay it started 50 but I've
been paying on it for 20 years and it
grew to 80.
that plan worked yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh my goodness what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is now
that you've done it you're never too old
we still feel like we're late in the
game but we have lots of time now to
catch up
um it's it's you if you don't start
you're never going to be in this in this
place and it's an amazing spot to be in
very cool proud of y'all yeah well done
thank you you're very neat people a lot
of fun watching you it's very very good
I had the opportunity to start over in
my 20s from a bankruptcy as you may know
and it is no fun yeah it is absolutely
no fun and um uh you guys did the same
thing you had a little delay before you
did it but we did the same exact thing
we reached the point we said okay uh
this plan is not working we need a new
plan uh keep doing the same thing over
and over again expect a different result
that's the definition of insanity and
you came to the same conclusions that
Sharon and I did we got to change
something and uh don't really care what
anybody thinks at that point we're not
taking a poll no we don't care if you
like our plan we're going to do it
you're willing to do anything even talk
to your brother about it I mean oh my
gosh you know yeah so I'm sure he was
cheering you on and happy for you yeah
yeah very good we um towards the end we
paid off everything in October and
that's when I think Karma cut up I don't
know what caught up with us but my
sister ended up passing away
unexpectedly and oh my goodness um Maya
got in a car accident with the hit and
run his car died and I mean we had just
started our emergency fund so we're both
looking at each other going are you
freaking out he's like no look are you
freaking out like no so it was just that
piece where we like okay we have money
in the bank we can help you know with my
sister's celebration of life we can cash
flow to cars we would have never been
able to do that we would have been such
a more horrible situation One More Mess
on top of it it would have been yeah so
it's really brought us a lot of Peace
yeah way to go yeah all right we've got
a copy of uh we've got the live and give
bundle for you the copy of The Total
Money Makeover book for you to give or
enjoy baby steps Millionaire's book to
give or enjoy and of course Financial
Peace University which you've been
through and you can give that to someone
now and pay it forward let's bring the
young guys up and tell us their names
and ages
there's a Justin he's 14 and I have
Benjamin here at 11. all right very cool
all right it's Bill and Amy Justin and
Benjamin from the Sacramento area 122
000 paid off in 43 months making 130 to
170 lots of extra jobs count it down
let's hear a debt free scream all right
everybody in three two one
yeah that's how we do it
I love it
this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
our scripture today Romans 12 2 don't
copy the behavior and customs of this
world but let God transform you into a
new person by changing the way you think
then you will learn to know God's will
for you which is good and pleasing and
perfect
the old version that I have memorized
says be not conformed to this world but
be transformed
by the renewing of your mind General
Patton said if everyone is thinking
alike then no one is thinking Amen to
that group thinking is not thinking Ken
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today Michelle is in Hawaii Maui to be
precise hey Michelle how are you
hi Dave doing good
doing good good how can we help
option or um CPA has suggested that we
get a cash balance plan
um I don't know what that is if that's a
good idea
they would like some help who has
suggested this
or CPA
your CPA okay has suggested you get a
cash balance
for what
for uh well we've maxed out our 401ks
for the year
[Music]
um
we've contributed the most to our IRA
um so that is just something she
suggested we look into okay are you
self-employed
we are
I think she's talking about setting up a
defined benefit plan how many team
members do you have
um how many employees do we have yes yes
uh we have about eight
how many how long have they been there
um
from one year to five years
and then my husband and myself that are
on payroll yeah okay and so you have a
401k at the company
uh we do yeah and you've maxed that out
Okay so we've maxed that out
okay I um have chosen not to do what
your CPA is suggesting
my 401k is maxed out my roths are maxed
out everything's maxed out and I have
not done any defined benefit plans or
any other internal pension plans
um because of what it would open me up
to in terms of the contributions I have
to make to the team number one but then
in addition to the match that I have in
their teams 401K number two uh there's
so many restrictions and so many um
regulations on when you can access that
money and what you can do with that
money that I didn't care for the lack of
Freedom so I have avoided this
okay
um and you can certainly do what you
want to do if you want to continue to
investigate it what I would do is start
to talk to someone in the investment
advice world uh click uh one of the
smartvestor pros at
ramseysolutions.com the people we
recommend I think they will tell you the
same thing I did sometimes
too often CPAs people in that World
um and and I come from that world
because I'm a math nerd uh the financial
world the CPA World sometimes we get all
caught up in the the mathematical
gymnastics and we enjoy finding products
that will do these gymnastics and uh but
then when we put those products out in
the wild in actual real life they end up
sucking pretty badly
uh the gymnastics of the math is kind of
a brain tease and it's kind of fun to
Think Through oh that's an unusual way
okay we've maxed this out here's a new
trick we can do but usually when I get
down in those things it
you can get stuck in them I mean you can
get stuck in a big hole there and uh
I've done that a couple of times uh over
the years in business with some legal
advice that was that kind of like
setting up structures for companies and
that kind of stuff really made huge
mistakes in that regard I I I've not
made the mistake you're getting ready to
make though that's a new one um I
avoided it because I saw the same signs
around it and um so at some point you
reach Point I've maxed out the normal
stuff the the easy to understand things
the simple things and the rest of it I'm
just going to end up paying some taxes
on oh by the way if you buy real estate
and it goes up in value you do not pay
taxes on the increase in value until you
sell it
so real estate grows tax deferred it's
called a capital gain oh by the way so
does a low turnover mutual fund and it's
real simple like I've got money in index
funds because they're low turnover I've
got money in real estate and I don't pay
any taxes on any of the increase in my
net worth because I don't cash them out
I don't sell them
now if I sell one of those mutual funds
or one of those pieces of real estate I
will pay taxes on the gain
but I can grow wealth without paying
taxes and without getting caught
in one of these
um products or processes that are
in my opinion mathematical gymnastics so
I don't do them Michelle and you can
learn about it further and decide if I'm
crazy or if your CPA is just caught up
in that I don't think you'll see CPA is
a bad person I just know the that type
of person we those of us that love math
will do something just because it's fun
with the math if we're not careful and
that'll get you into a mess
Leilani is with us in Wyoming hi Lalani
how are you
I'm great how are you better than I
deserve what's up
well um I have a
chair I've been trying to get
I had an exit team but they failed to
exit me and so I'm wondering if I can
just quit claim deed
problem is you don't have a deed
is that different than a warranty deed
a quit claim deed is different than a
warranty deed but you don't have a deed
to your timeshare oh
you just own a portion of one week or a
week or a portion of a year or whatever
and um you know the time shares are what
uh those of us that hate them we call
them legalized fraud
it is the worst business on the planet
they screw more people than anybody else
I'm so sorry I'm sorry the exit didn't
work we've worked with companies trying
to get people out they got in trouble I
mean it's a that industry is filthy it's
a filthy horrible business and you
should anybody time someone says
timeshare run out of the room like your
hair is on fire because it's getting
ready to be somebody's getting ready to
light your freaking hair on fire get out
of there so I truly uh do not know a
good way to get out of a timeshare but
quit claim to eating it won't work
because you don't have a deed you have
to have a you have to have an owner
position ownership position and with a
timeshare you don't technically have an
ownership position you have a contract
and that's different than an ownership
position ownership position where you
have a deed is recorded at a courthouse
and there is a deed on file with a
register of deeds which gives you the
ownership position can this timeshare
thing is just a debacle there's powerful
people that are protecting this scum and
that's what's really going on uh it is a
system uh product and you're a victim
very lucrative it's very lucrative it
makes you mean billions and billions of
dollars and they keep screwing consumers
hand over fist and uh just stay away
from anybody that says timeshare
horrible product yeah did I mention that
it's horrible oh yeah was I clear I hope
I was clear and if you sell timeshares
You Are by definition scum I hope I was
not unclear I think you got that one
yeah really yeah if your little boy
sells time shares tell your little boy
to get a good job a good screwing people
seriously yeah oh my god well they're
protected by legislatures in state and
in the federal government because of the
money that they're doing they've even
gotten some of the media on their side
without dropped so much coin into
attorney general's pockets that's right
they've dropped so much coin into the
media's pockets it's
unbelievable yeah they are filth trash
and nastiness I'm so sorry little lilani
I don't know how to tell you to get out
of it these days there was a period of
time that we were able to get a whole
bunch of people out with the exit
programs the exit programs have fallen
apart there's a few of them doing it
still on doing it well you might get a
good attorney sometimes a good attorney
that will sue their butts off for the
fraud that they conducted on you they'll
probably find a hole or two in the in
the fraudulent sales presentation and
sometimes a good attorney can get you
exited you might try that but you're
going to write some checks you're going
to spend some money to get out of this
mess I'm so sorry you can't even give
them away no it's awful and I don't know
who you'd give them who would you give
them to somebody you didn't like I like
my worst enemy here's my time shares
that puts the salary of the Ramsay show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]
foreign
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsey Baby
Steps go to ramsesolutions.com and click
on the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]